أعيش في ظل السلطات التي تقول إن أكثر من
2000 شخص لقوا حتفهم بعد
عاصفة كبيرة وفيضانات كارثية، وهناك ما بين
خمسة إلى ستة آلاف شخص آخرين في عداد المفقودين،
حدث هذا في شرق ليبيا حيث
تعرضت مدينة درنة لضربة شديدة بشكل خاص،
ويقول المسؤولون إن قرويين بأكملها
جرفتهم المياه  مع هطول الأمطار لمدة ثمانية أشهر تقريبًا
في يوم واحد، وصف أحد المسؤولين
درنة بأنها مدينة أشباح حيث
الجثث متناثرة في العديد من الأماكن، حيث
انقطعت خطوط الهاتف مما يجعل
جهود الإنقاذ أكثر صعوبة،
ويقول خبراء الأرصاد الجوية إن المزيد من الأمطار في الطريق مثل
هذا الخطاة  التطورات التي تتابعها ليدي جوكر
من دبي، لقد استغرق الأمر
بعض الوقت للحصول على المعلومات
بسبب ما حدث وبسبب
المنطقة ولكننا نحصل على
إحساس حقيقي بها الآن، أليس كذلك، نعم
نحن كذلك وننظر إلى  الأرقام
الآن حيث أن أكثر من 2000 شخص
فقدوا حياتهم، هذا الرقم هو في كثير من
الحسابات أقل من الواقع لأنه
حوالي 6000 شخص في عداد المفقودين،
وهناك تقارير عن جثث ملقاة حول
الناس جرفتها هذه
الأمطار الغزيرة مما أدى إلى تفاقم الوضع  كان هناك
سدان انهارا بسبب ضغط هطول
الأمطار، ثم تسبب ذلك في
مزيد من الضغط مما أدى إلى
ذوبان منازل ومدن بأكملها، وقد رأينا
الكثير من القرويين، الأمر لا يقتصر على درنة فحسب،
بل يبدو أنها نوع
من مركز المأساة  هذا ما
يحدث الآن، لقد رأينا
بنغازي تؤثر بشكل كبير على أختار
أيضًا وعلى القرويين الأصغر الآخرين الذين
هم حاليًا تحت الماء، إنه أمر
كارثي تمامًا من حيث ما نراه
ولكن
هيئة الطوارئ والإسعاف تقول إنه كان هناك
نقص في الاستعداد
ولم تكن السلطات تراقب
الأحوال الجوية بشكل كاف أو ترى
ما تفعله المستويات وتراقب ما
سيفعله الطقس وقد
ضربت العاصفة دانيال اليونان وكذلك تركيا
ثم انتقلت إلى الأجزاء الشرقية من
ليبيا للبحث والإنقاذ حاليا.
جارية ولكن كما تقول، من الصعب للغاية
فيما يتعلق بالاتصالات، في الواقع
لا تستطيع بعض فرق الإنقاذ الوصول إلى
الموظفين الآخرين لأنهم محاصرون، والعديد من
المناطق معزولة الآن، ولا
نعرف مدى مدى محاولة الناس
الخروج من المنطقة.  سلامة العديد من هؤلاء
الأشخاص الذين حوصروا في
المناطق التي غمرتها الفيضانات ولكن ماكس الوضع مروع بشكل لا يصدق،
أعني بعض الصور
التي نرى أشخاصًا معلقين على
سيارات يجلسون على المباني على أسطح المنازل
في الوقت الحالي، نعلم أن تركيا ترسل المساعدة
لهم.  سنرسل ثلاث طائرات و168
فردًا إلى بنغازي سيتم
نشرهم، كما ترسل الإمارات العربية المتحدة أيضًا المساعدة وكذلك
قطر والأمم المتحدة متواجدة حاليًا
على الأرض ولكن هناك نقص في
القيادة المركزية أو النظام لمحاولة
إخراج المساعدات في أسرع وقت ممكن
نظرًا لوجود فصيلين متنافسين في
الشرق والنفايات التي
كانت تتنافس على السلطة ولكن هذا النوع من
الطوارئ يتطلب عملاً منسقًا من قبل
الحكومة لمحاولة الحصول على المساعدة
في أسرع وقت ممكن،
نعم، دعونا نأمل أن يعملوا معًا،
شكرًا لك.  جزيل الشكر للانضمام إلينا
من دبي،
حسنًا، عاصفة قوية ومميتة
أطلقت العنان لفيضانات مدمرة في شرق
ليبيا، نقلت تقارير وسائل الإعلام الحكومية عن
مسؤول يقول إنه يخشى مقتل أكثر من 2000 شخص
في
مدينة واحدة، ولم يذكر المسؤول مصدرًا
لذلك.  قالت أرقامه والهلال الأحمر في
وقت سابق إنهم يقدرون ما بين 150 إلى 200 50
شخصًا يجب أن أقول إنهم لقوا حتفهم في مدينة
درنة الآن بسبب الأمطار الغزيرة التي تغمر
كما ترون هذا المستشفى أيضًا
غمرت الشوارع وانقطعت خدمة الهاتف، وحصلت
المنطقة على أكثر من
اثنين  - ثلثي هطول الأمطار السنوي المعتاد
هناك في يوم واحد فقط جاء من
البقايا التي تتذكرها كنت أتحدث
عن الأسبوع الماضي من العاصفة دانيال التي
ضربت اليونان الأسبوع الماضي، أريد
إحضار بن وايدهام الخاص بنا والانضمام إلي
الآن للمزيد والمزيد  بن، هذا
مدمر للغاية، فقط أعطنا
إحساسًا بما تسمعه من
السلطات هذه الساعة،
حسنًا، الشخص الذي قدم هذا الادعاء
هو رئيس الوزراء أسامة حمد وهو
رئيس وزراء
الحكومة الانفصالية لشرق ليبيا ومقرها
بنغازي، وقال  أن ما لا يقل عن
2000 شخص لقوا حتفهم نتيجة
لهذه الفيضانات في مدينة درنة
بالإضافة إلى أنه يدعي أن ما
يصل إلى 5000 شخص قد يكونون في عداد المفقودين الآن لقد زرت
درنة، وهي مدينة يبلغ عدد سكانها حوالي
مائة ألف شخص في أسفل
جبل الآن، قاع نهر جاف،
يمر وادي عبر الظهرنة ولكن يبدو أنه
نتيجة لكمية الأمطار التي
هطلت على دانيال ملقاة في تلك المنطقة كما
قلت ثلثي هطول
الأمطار السنوي في فقط  في أحد الأيام،
اجتاحت وسط تلك المدينة
وما نراه على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
هي مشاهد تذكرنا بما
يحدث في المغرب الآن من حيث
حجم الدمار، والآن
ليس من الواضح تمامًا مصدر هذا الدمار.
هذا الادعاء بما لا يقل عن ألفي قتيل
وخمسة آلاف مفقود هو أه رئيس الوزراء
حمد لم يذكر
أه هذا المصدر ولكن من الواضح أن هناك
أضرار جسيمة في درنة وربما
خسائر فادحة في الأرواح وكذلك كما
قلت الأحمر الليبي  جمعية الهلال
تقول ربما يصل عدد القتلى إلى 250 شخصًا،
لكن مجرد النظر إلى تلك الصور
يشك المرء في أنه ربما
يكون عدد القتلى أعلى بكثير، نعم
بالتأكيد هذه الصور تبدو
كارثية للغاية عندما ننظر إلى بعض
الصور التي حصلنا عليها من  بين عشية وضحاها فيما يتعلق
بما قاله رئيس الوزراء
هو أنه يطلب الصحة الدولية هل
يطلب من الآخرين المساعدة
لأن هذه الصور حقا أه
صادمة حقا أه
نعم الليبيون
يطلبون المساعدة بشدة أه في الواقع إلى
قال رئيس الإمارات أنهم
سوف يرسلون
مساعدات عاجلة على الفور والأمم المتحدة
تطلب المساعدة أه وكذلك قلت
ليس واضحا تماما
مدى الضرر
عدد القتلى عدد المفقودين ولكن من الواضح أن هناك  هي
حاجة ماسة للمساعدة والليبيون
يطلبون أه ذلك على الفور قال
نحث على الحاجة إلى المساعدة الإغاثية بشكل
واضح بن ويدمان لنا هناك شكرا
جزيلا بن
شكرا لك